my own way every time every time every
time
every gal wants their own way every girl
wants to be treated by princess every
girl wants to eat off your plate
if I need someone that's going to treat
me like a princess like giving you
compliments and stuff and just making
you feel good you know it's bad you
ain't chasing the man there are so many
men that will treat you like a princess
look at her look at her she I'm sorry
you might you could argue how hot she is
in the comments I don't really care if
she's hot enough to get a guy that
treats her like a princess but she
doesn't want that guy no girl actually
likes guys that put them on pedestals
I'm sorry I don't care what any of y'all
female simps say when you're like oh no
we like the nice guy stop it you don't
want a guy you can walk all over and
it's extremely unattractive when you
walk all over a guy